geheimtipp
nikes sauber kriegen
also gerade wenn
der mann kennt was er in so bestimmten
stellen da kriegt man das nicht weg und
das ist hier erobert sich das auf und
ist alles scheiße und man kann sie in
die waschmaschine tun
der gag ist man muss es vorher in einem
kissenbezug tun oder an einen decken
bezog damit dass damit der das leder
oder die dieses plastik nicht an die
kante von der von der trommel kommt das
eisen und dann aufschauen also einfach
rein tun zu knüpfen reinmachen
niedrigste schleuder zahl kältestes
kälteste temperatur und kriegt ihr
solche wieder raus und dann geht es voll
ab und danach mit zeitungspapier
ausstopfen damit sie keine falten werfen
so und dann sind sie danach ach ja und
vorher die schnürsenkel rausnehmen weil
wenn man die drin last kriegen diese
eklige schlieren an den stellen wo sie
in den löchern sind und die einfach auch
in grenzen